on se valent et home office you
fabre
il
honte à toi
ce mois coca light
voilà
merci après j'irai à vancouver mais
c'est pas grave
soit j'ai vu ton sport qui m'a dit la
vie c'est bien vous donne un coup dans
le nez
m
bonjour il faut avoir une coupe de
champagne chocolats et en heure
ok bon relais
matra et pas essayer
mon père s'il vous plaît ma boîte bien
qu'elle ait une coupe de champagne
s'il vous plaît
notons qu'à gagner une coupe de
champagne
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît on voit le sourire
allo
et
m
ça va quand on peux rien s'il vous plaît
oui voilà
j'accueille maintenant vers winter et
gilles paquet brenner
weiner ophélie winter bonsoir c'est
dedans
j'ai gagné un 7 d'or bien aidé au
bien au fini c'est pour pâques on vous
compare à loana vous êtes fait brunir un
peu les cheveux bon vous savez ouais non
savez j'ai envie de rester comme ça j'en
avais gilles paquet brenner dont vous
êtes le réalisateur d'un film qui
s'appelle les jolies choses avec marion
cotillard stomy bugzy patrick bruel
titoff et ophélie winter voulez que je
fasse le pitch vous le faites
allez-y je vais faire le pitch et ça
c'est l'histoire de deux soeurs
alors il ya deux soeurs jumelles y en a
une qui s'appelle lucie une qui
s'appelle marie mais elles ont
absolument rien à voir l'une avec
l'autre
lucie c'est un peu la bimbo d'infos
prête à tout pour réussir
marie c'est le côté obscur repliée sur
elle-même complètement à titia non non
non non non plus les produits liquides
comme qui donc la deuxième mari elle est
complètement repliée sur elle même elle
est complètement bunkérisé et un jour
lucie est sollicité pour faire un disque
elle sait pas chanter
elle demande à marie de prendre sa place
et pendant ce temps là lui six suicides
et marie est obligé d'endosser la
personnalité de sa soeur c'était une
personnalité qui lui ressemble pas du
tout évidemment
alors il ya un témoin de l'histoire le
seul qui est au courant de la faire
c'est nicolas donc qui est un ami à un
ami de l'uci qui est jouée par stomy
bugzy voilà alors le rôle des deux
jumelles est interprétée par marion
cotillard patrick bruel il fait très
très bien d'ailleurs le patron d'une
maison de disques ophélie vous êtes une
égérie de la nuit dans ce film on peut
dire ça j'ai pas comment tu me décrirais
tu toi c'est un jeune noir
on jouera comme ça c'est bien il s'est
tiré du livre de virginie
c'est un fils d'une grande inventivité
sur le plan formel c'est très très rare
en france de voir des films aussi
sophistiquée sur plan visuel non ouais
mais en même temps il ya une lame de
fond là qu'est en train d'arriver bon
enfin il ya ceux qu'on connaît
jan kounen mathieu kassovitz christophe
gornès moi je pense que je fais un peu
partie de la deuxième génération de ce
que j'appelle les réalisateurs cinéphage
et cinéphiles c'est à dire qu'ils ont
été élevés au cinéma américain et aussi
au cinéma de france est conduit par
l'assurance de sauter aussi dans les
salles de bistrot en fait donc à une
évidence et que l'on a grandi avec
stallone phare sénégal etc
et puis par ce biais là on est arrivé à
un cinéma un peu plus pointu et et voilà
mais j'ai pas fait d'école j'ai pas fait
tout ça quoi c'est un moyen métrage qui
s'appelait le marquis un qui avait déjà
eu pas mal de succès qui avait été très
remarquée et dans le film la chance que
vous avez c'est que tous les acteurs
soient participation parce qu'il croyait
au projet oui enfin le marquis c'est un
peu une histoire de fou c'est un truc
que je me suis levé un matin jeudi dans
quinze jours on va faire un film et en
traitant il ya patrick bruel semi bugzy
qui se sont trouvés dedans mais one le
besco vanessa des mots et puis des amis
à moi tenir un mini-match touboul et
mais là je suis en train de le remonter
et pour le ressortir après je pense
directement en vidéo et ce qui est bien
c'est que ça m'a permis de bach on se
rend compte tout ce qu'on commence à
travailler ensemble et pouvoir
poursuivre après sur les jolies choses
alors à une semaine du tournage vous
aviez toujours pas d'actrice pour
interpréter votre ange noir
pourquoi vous avez choisi ophélie
finalement j'ai un peu forcé vous faites
moi j'ai un copain qui m'appelle j'étais
à saint tropez ou champio et kimi il ya
un rôle super pourtant il faut que tu
appelles les metteurs en scène donc
j'appelle gilles il me demande d'en
monter à paris je remonte darbas et je
supplie de me prendre pour faire ce rôle
parce que c'était un rôle très trash et
que j'avais envie de faire un truc comme
ça pour changer enfin et
j'ai un petit peu un peu violer c'est ce
que j'aime bien dire ça mais c'est vrai
il disait tout le temps je voudrais une
sorte de fait les winter leurs geôliers
quelqu'un qui le dit pourquoi tu prends
pas ophélie winter tout simplement
et voilà ça fait la blague il à la vraie
ophélie dans son film avait une chanson
du film qui est vachement bien
samson d'accès l'or noir très belle très
belle chanson qui va être un tube en
plus non c'est bien
alors fini c'est la forme j'ai déclaré
vous avez déclaré le plus difficile dans
ce métier c'est de durer j'étais
tellement jeunes au départ et puis il a
fallu que je réalise ce qui m'arrivait
ensuite tout s'emballe et sap est
violent ouais
et c'est vrai que pour vous tout s'est
mis en marche en même temps la musique
la télévision c'était ça a été très
rapide et très violent non c'est parti
en flammes
c'est un peu à cause de vous en même
temps je préfère me dire que les gens ne
le savent pas mais j'avais fait une
émission mais je mets mes dents longues
dans le jury a on vous voit vous m'aviez
mis dans le jury d'une émission que vous
produisiez et donc quelqu'un de m6
marbre remarquez ce jour là et m'a
proposé d'autres émissions et après tout
est parti comme ça et c'est vrai que là
j'ai fait un break les deux dernières
années et que c'est pendant ces deux
dernières années que j'ai réalisé ce qui
m'était arrivé on va voir l'émission on
parler de titre peut-être qu'on trouvera
un détient classé dans ce classement
dans une dizaine d'années
le ferry tu nous vois pas un album du
mois on a des simples pour l'instant des
40 citoyens album en préparation ont
fermé nous sentir en août 20 août
est-ce que évidemment comme c'est prévu
on aura quelques titres de prins dessus
bernard rappaz 40 bis alors à deux voire
trois bon d'accord
et pour la rentrée j'ai appris qu'à
priori tu devais peut-être chanter un
peu au zénith en première partie de
certains artistes voient c'est pour
l'instant on va voir c'était la première
apparition de pedro winter
la télévision avait été choisi pour un
point devant le jury effectivement de la
coupe du monde de la séduction
c'était ça la coupe dix30 séduction et
puis voilà et c'est laurent ce petit sur
m6 qui vous avec vous a remarqué et qui
a décidé de vous faire faire date et
l'heure tout a démarré en même temps il
y avait l'album il y avait là il y avait
la télé c'était très rapide ça a été ça
tu es fou et c'était un peu dépassé par
les événements pendant un mois ou deux
équipes rendent un peu le melon et après
je me suis retombée c'est un pied de
biche speed vous étiez surmédiatisé à un
moment on peut le dire moi c'était un
peu et je fasse si vous vous souvenez
quand on était petits avaient des
bouquins qui s'appelait martine à la
plage du ski j'avais un peu l'impression
d'être martin dans la presse gérer
n'importe quoi aux figures monoprix
ophélie fait tout ce qui fait n'importe
quoi wen jiabao ophélie au revoir on va
paraître jeudi
oui
alors vous êtes né en 1974 est la fille
du chanteur hollandais david alexandre
winter et de kathy winters mannequin à
l'époque et qui est aujourd'hui votre
agent rect les parents se séparent quand
vous avez deux ans et vous allez vivre
donc en france arrivée en france et
vivra neuilly et votre père s'en va
habiter aux usa et vous dit en parlant
de lui qu'il était lobotomisés du coeur
oui parce qu'en fait j'ai compris super
tard en fait quand mon grand père est
juste avant que mon grand père s'en
aille
enfin m eur sur son lit d'hôpital il m'a
raconté un truc est parce qu on est juif
donc et dans la famille quand la les
nazis sont arrivés en hollande mais mes
grands parents ont placé mon père dans
une famille catholique et plus les nazis
se rapprochait plus les familles passé
mon père de famille en famille comme ça
donc il a dû faire cinq ou six familles
et du coup il a recréé ça quand il a été
adulé il fait des gosses partout je
découvre des frères des soeurs hollande
en belgique c'est n'importe quoi s'est
il a été très généreux de sa graine mon
papa c'est votre mère qui vous avez levé
catchy donc point d'argent quand vous
étiez enfant
pas du tout je me souviens de tout le
pire dont je me souvienne c'est quand on
était à l'école en loin on avait un
appartement et on le louer pendant qu'on
était à l'école on aller habiter chez
des copains aux primaires et un peu
d'argent pour nos filets à manger donc
c'était situe souvent les les pâtes et
les patates
ouais pas temps de manger de la viande
c'était la fête mais bon man a assuré
la sirène et malgré tout vous avez quand
même le sens du du spectacle chevillée
au corps parce que vous faites votre
premier disque à l'âge de 6 ans aux
ménages étaient pas consciente 1 la mère
qui est je voulais chanter donc elle
même impôt déguisé et faire ce truc là
et j'étais super en colère après elle
mais on a récidivé à l'âge de 12 ans et
là j'ai dit ça suffit
tous mes copains à l'école ce côté là
c'est bon j'ai dit à tous mes potes on
verrai quand je serai grande ça m'a mis
la rage du quand je serai grande je
serai un indice que ça marchera mieux
dès que vous étiez assez dur quand vous
étiez petit à oui mais c'est pas vos
propos pour dix balles vous arranger les
affaires de vaud de vos camarades
d'école j'ai en fait j'étais grande en
sais quoi maintenant peu maternelle en
primaire
j'étais assez grande par rapport aux
autres donc j'ai cassé la gueule pour 10
francs aux toilettes je faisais des
spectacles jeux rival est content de mes
copines et après je ça s'est retourné
contre moi parce qu'au lycée j'étais
naine pendant trois ans je sais un peu
40 et là c'était plutôt mois pour le
tabasser jeudi la plus petite de la
classe et c'est un petit peu une
métaphore de votre vie parce que
finalement tout le monde va vers vous et
puis après vous vous retrouvez un peu là
c'est ce qui vient de se passer pendant
deux trois ans vous retrouvez un peu la
naine de la classe mais c'est plus c'est
bien ça fait du bien de se prendre une
petite claque dans la tronche comme ça
en devient bien je te montre et vous
prenez votre revanche à l'époque où les
grandes gigues ne sont plus à la mode et
c'est la fin dès la fin des plates et
vous avec toi un exact ça m'a sauvé la
vie ça j'ai commencé à être mannequin
cette époque là je partis de chez ma
mère je sais pas j'avais 17 ans jugent
être mannequin est un petit peu rigoler
parce que je n'ai je pas 1 m 68 et
j'avais des saints
triple sens de tour de poitrine c'est
vrai ça m'est arrivé d'un coup en plus
jusqu'à 17 ans j'étais comme la table
mais c'est pas la sécurité mais non
collomb sur la plage voilà fatwa toi toi
je vais te la fais ça je dis chapeau
pour les arrivées
[Applaudissements]
la chanson
alors à neuilly sur le même palier que
vous habitez les frères mc h et y en a
un qui vous dit vous avez un physique de
chanteuse les phrases de film ça toi tu
veux faire des chapeaux et non pas
encore et oui donc le comité c'était mon
voisin et que je voyais sortir son chien
depuis des années je pensais que c'était
quelqu'un de bien donc j'ai commencé à
travailler avec lui et ses frères s'est
avéré que ça c'est pas super bien passé
donc j'ai fait un divorce de producteurs
qui a duré un an et qui m'a empêché de
chanter pendant un an
non non vous avez pas chanter j'ai
profité pour faire de la télé sur m6
mais en expliquant quand même à qui
voulait l'entendre que ce n'était pas le
but de votre vie et que c'était juste un
un passage c'est l'époque aussi de votre
relation avec prins alors on n'a jamais
su ce qui s'est passé parce qu'un jour
je vous ai posé la question dans un
journal et vous m'avez dit le premier
qui parle doit payer je sais plus
combien 1000 $ à l'autre c'est pas vrai
j'avais une petite amourette avec
transport il ya prescription maintenant
toi si on peut en parler foot oui c'est
fini
ouais les nombreux voyages à minneapolis
ans mais j'arrive ici me dire faire la
téloche toi j'étais encore à l'école
j'avais 17 ans je tente quand l'école
ouais ça commençait vachement tôt il le
vendredi soir quand j'ai quitté l'école
je prenais l'avion je faisais paris
boston boston minneapolis des gens
venaient le dimanche
inutile de dire que les devoirs et les
courges n'importe quoi c'est pas ça ça a
duré longtemps ça vous devez jouer
l'aventuré galabru t'aurais pas
redoublés non plus
après ya eu ça
j'arrête
quoi
j
alors ça c'était en fait le quatrième
essai discographique et 8,3 échec avant
et c'est génial parce que vous dites
finalement au point où j'en suis
maintenant je me suis tellement planter
autant faire ce qui me plaît
glorifier dieu voilà c'est l'idée que
vous aviez et dieu vous a aidé
apparemment aide toi le ciel t'aidera un
truc comme ça je sais pas mais j'avais
vraiment envie de parler de ça je me
suis toute façon personne ça n'intéresse
personne dieu fin de mes copains quand
je leur ai fait lire ma chanson homonyme
et attend les n'importe quoi et
finalement mais voilà c'était la belle
surprise et alors là c'est un peu le
début du délire parce que vous déclarez
à l'issue de ce succès j'ai toujours eu
l'impression d'être prédestiné bon
jusque là d'avoir une boule de feu au
dessus de la tête
oui elle à l'époque j'avais un peu de
mal à m'exprimer donc non mais j'ai pas
une boule de feu mais j'avais fini je
peux pas en parler là mais qu'est ce qui
s'était passé j'ai fait une séance
d'hypnose une fois pour arrêter de fumer
et c'est à dire et ça va pas marcher ça
peut marcher mais c'est tant mieux
et j'avais une image comme ça de deux je
voyais les gens comme des boules de feu
c'était en fait c'étaient les âmes qui
étaient comme des petites boules de feu
qu'ils y qui parlaient en faisant de la
télépathie fait un truc j'en avais
l'impression au moment où vous aviez
aucune maîtrise de votre carrière si on
faisait un petit peu tout ce qu'on vous
demandez où quand en fait j'étais choix
assez aléatoire n'est pas connue et en
rêve depuis que tu es petit tu fais
n'importe quoi j'ai dit à une fois que
j'aurais pu faire une ouverture de
prisunic avec un string panthère
j'aurais fait n'importe quoi pour être
connu ce que j'en rêvais et comme ça un
peu marcher je me suis dit ma mère me
disait tout le temps que profite profite
parce que ça peut très bien s'arrêter
demain donc je me disais
vite oui alors oui à toi oui je vous
retrouve à dire oui à tout le monde à
faire des trucs qui n'avait ni queue ni
tête
ce que je ne sais plus aujourd'hui et
cette histoire avec mc solaar s'est
terminé comme en bas comme une rupture
de gens normaux c'est une rupture a pas
à faire
ouais normal kouakou la durée quand même
temps cinq ans et demi
m
alors que les winter comme vous êtes
croyante on va vous faire une interview
croyance en la bouche
[Applaudissements]
ce qui se passait mais qui sont des gens
par ce genre d incident a fait sur ce
soit l'école c'est parfait si tu as la
parole d'accord cela dit on peut encore
s'exprimer
bien interview croyances ophélie winter
est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui ouais voilà ça sert
quand vous étiez enfant au lieu de vous
créer une espèce de vies parallèles
comme font les enfants avec des
personnages et où vous souhaitez dieu
ouais moi c'est en fait j'ai compris
encore plus tard que c'était le manque
de pair et qu'en fait vous de parler à
mon père je parlais à dieu tous les
jours j'avais besoin magnum dans ma vie
voilà est-ce que vous croyez à l'amour
oui oui j'ai j'y crois encore ouais vous
avez été assez tardive parce que votre
premier garçon où vous l'avez connu dont
vous aviez 17 ans à ivry relations
sexuelles oui oui j'étais pas j'étais un
mec
j'étais vachement mec je serai mais avec
moi c'est mon frère ouais tu vois que tu
es filles face à moi à quel âge tu n'es
pas prête à l'emploi
j'avais pas de sens jusqu'à 17 ans donc
quand un peu voilà j'avais pas le matos
je vous cherchez un père pour un bébé je
cherche un père de même un homme pour
moi d'abord cela les arrange personne et
après éventuellement pour un bébé
ouais vous dites il faut quelqu'un qui
m'aime pour mon âme et pas seulement
pour mon physique parce que dans 20 ans
j'ai le cul par terre et je fais des
nues avec mes seins c'est vrai que c'est
pas très encourageant quand même bien
non c'est pas terrible non mais c'est
que c'est dur à trouver un accord je
suis paranoïaque tu avec les mecs j'ai
l'impression que le jour je vais être
enceinte ils vont aller sauter à droite
à gauche on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer
cherchez quoi comme genre de mec j'ai
pas de genre c'est un mec avec qui je me
marre qu'ils soient gentils qui même
crois c'est ouvert à tout le monde peut
poser sa candidature jean-louis oui
voilà vous avez le site tous pauvres en
partie sur france 2 la question de la
fiche numéro 69 c'est vous qui me poser
une question
les rôles sont inversés je vous écoute
69 question pieds rires ouais ok vous et
moi une question c'est est-ce que tu
m'aimes j'aurais pu être en vérité c'est
que j'aurais aimé être ton pygmalion on
en parlera est ce que vous croyez en
vous maintenant oui depuis peu est ce
que vous croyez aux anges gardiens ouais
j'espère vraiment des anges gardiens
c'est un fait en fait c'est un autre un
autre nous dans un espèce de l'univers
parallèle
moi je suis comme ça aux fantômes oui un
superman non non non au père noël non
plus maintenant au pouvoir de pikachu
way à mort vous voyez à l'effet des
crèmes antirides
non mais j'espère je me plais à y croire
jean de placebo ça marche la
réincarnation vous y croyez ouais
voudrais vous réincarner en coiffe
blanche à bret carr et ses bouffées
dormir d'ouvriers à céline dion et alors
tu as d'autres questions non mais c'est
joker c'est cgil qui répond qu'un ouais
ouais quand on répond pas ça passe à la
personne d'à côté c'est un vêtement
si je dis non à ma première télé je
crois pas en céline dion j'ai l'air con
quand même si tu dis oui aussi
est ce que vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
presley
oui oui paraît qu'il a éclaté sur les
chiottes enfin qu'il prenait tellement
de cachet de gens pour dormir pour
manger pour maigrir pour l'un qu'il a
éclaté je suis convié la fidélité dans
le couple et g non maintenant moi oui
j'essaie d'être moi je suis fidèle à
laurent blanc je te jure ça n'a pas nui
je vous voyais l'amour son sexe non non
quand on aime il faut que ça vous croyez
au sexe sans amour
ouais bien sûr est ce que voudrait que
patrick fiori peut se remettre de son
aventure avec lara fabian et avoir dit
trop dur et trop lente iris est ce que
vous croyez qu'on peut faire l'amour
cinq fois de suite
ah oui je ne croirai confie chantal deux
garçons là en photo a du talent je ne
pense pas il winter
selon lui
mais c'est encore un petit peu de dire
bonjour dans les langes assez activement
il faut que je dis ou s'être approché de
moi pour m'embrasser
j'espère vraiment pour dire c'est
réellement je ne plaisante pas essayé de
lui parler moustache ophélie non mais je
l'adoré jai ouais c'est qu'il est culte
mais ça y est c'est vrai c'est vrai ça y
est c'est fini vous êtes culte c'est
fini j'ai vu quand on écoute après les
habitudes qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire 2
alors donc ophélie vous avez déclaré
dans le magazine rolling stone
aujourd'hui aller à la télévision faire
là ophélie winter que l'on connaît ça me
panique je fais parce que c'est
nécessaire mais fondamentalement c'est
pas moi parce que la carapace de
superficialité que j'avais bas n'est
plus là aujourd'hui je suis à poil voilà
c'est vrai que ça me gonfle un peu
dallas la série je préfère être un
studio et faire de la musique plutôt que
d'aller raconter comment j'ai fait mon
album
mais bon chez vous c'est différent parce
que c'est cool et qu'on peut être
détendu ce gentil mais c'est vrai
maintenant vous montrer que je suis tel
que vous êtes d'ailleurs c'est vrai dans
la villa d'arthur à nice on vous avez eu
votre tranche du matin comme vous dites
qui est pas pire que la tranche du soir
jour une différence quand même quand
même tu peux mais pas tant que ça
finalement ça avant de les fermer a
expliqué j'étais hyper flipper vous dis
ça je suis malade d'avoir accepté ça
j'ai fait une connerie quoi vous étiez
pas sûr d'avoir raison et en fait quand
on est arrivé là bas vous a été super
bien accueilli
vous dites pas du tout comme ophélie
winter pourquoi parce que c'était des
européens et vous connaissez pas non ils
m'ont traité comme quelqu'un d'humain et
pas comme quelqu'un de connu encore une
fois donc j'ai passé cinq jours de
vacances on insère des salades être avec
des potes ça va découvrir des gens et je
me suis vraiment détendue ça fait
plaisir et quand je fais ça commence
les journalistes qui me sont tombés
dessus ça m'a angoissé je me suis dit ça
y est je redeviens ophélie winter
showbiz c'est un beauf les coins vous
regardez un petit peu nice people jean
jean j'étais dans l'angoissé maintenant
je sais ce que c'est mais pendant trois
minutes je vis on va me demander ce que
je pense de l'iphone et je ne savais pas
effectivement c'est quand il s'agissait
j'ai cru que c'était un péplum mais
parce que quand vous avez passé juste
avant vous êtes inquiet face à cette
date rx je n'ai jamais dit
comme hard mais je n'ai jamais vu non
mais je ne suis pas plus cher pour ça
que j'aimerais volontiers le voit c'est
que c'est bon pour votre carrière de
fermat sp paul ophélie je ne pense pas à
ma carrière
le problème certainement que ça va être
c'est pas une bonne bonne méthode mais
je pense pas à ma carrière je pense à ce
qui me fait plaisir et je vous avais
marre et 10 avec moi je me suis je me
suis éclatée reculer le 20 février
74 e ri c'est tout c'est bien déjà
c'est une journée se ressourcer dans là
explique paula jeu franchement je ne
sais pas j'ai une clause de
confidentialité dans mon contrat avant
mais ça doit être bien payé parce que ça
vaut quand même le coup j'étais la
première j'ai essuyé les plâtres
vous savez pas où j'allais dans tous les
cas ma fille tu n'as pas voulu via les
toits moi je peux pas moi j'ai des
blattes en ce moment pendant que ce à
quoi des blattes
et les blacks comme les oeufs sous les
aisselles après c'est un vrai merdier
béton mais pas sur le périnée
ah non surtout l'art à la plaque du
périnée et coordonnées entre du périnée
fasciné par nombre d'histoires d'amour
qu'on peut monter sur des plateaux non
homogène et de pulsions sexuelles au
affective qui avec des gens que j'aime
passionnément mais les parents les amis
j'en arrive et lui comme chabat il est
comme chabat janser qui rit pas souvent
mais quand il rit on est content qu'il
ya des gens comme ça quand on voit leurs
dents quand on voit leur sourire c'est
vrai j'en ai c'est la classe et des gens
qui sont en vulgaire ya des gens qui
sont classe l'agencé la classe top
classe c par rapport à d'autres un
conduit ici oui des gougnafiers deux
premiers des connards tu peux dire
quelques mots c'est pas du foutage
acteurs reconnus non marc revient à
people quand vous dites sérieusement
qu'on vous dit
c'est la plus belle semaine de ma vie
c'est dans le contrat ça ou c'est
simplement sur le prompteur non vous
connaissez je suis pas comme ça je n'ai
pas j'ai pas l'habitude de dire ce qu'on
me demande de dire bien au contraire est
vraiment quand je suis sorti j'étais sur
un sur un nuage quoi ça va durer
longtemps je suis vite redescendu j'ai
vite recommencer à travailler dans la
vraie vie mais pendant cinq six jours
j'étais vraiment décalé si formidable ce
jour non mais non c'est pas eux qui sont
formidables c'est le fait d'être séparé
de tous les trucs chiants genre
portables et antennes rêvant thibault si
tu veux
bon résultat notre équipe sur la musique
au fait d un éclair vraiment dizier
[Musique]
de quoi
j
oui
chez
j'ai
m
la méfiance
géant
[Musique]
m
l'étude
[Musique]
m
ouais ouais
voilà le dernier cite souvent mieux ses
excès
dernier
il s'appelle ex
c'est là bien sûr
[Musique]
oh
voilà tout le monde le fait donc le
deuxième single du nouvel album
d'ophélie tout le monde le fait genre je
peux vous le dire tout de suite c'est la
masturbation dont il s'agit l'eau n'a ni
de regard a changé en deux zones
mais le brand losange avait coupé
les texans novelli tout le monde
bah oui bah oui bah oui quand je vous
vois là vous êtes du niveau de christina
aguilera jennifer lopez pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas autant de succès que ces
gonzesses
c'est pas moi qui décide si quand même
c'est peut-être vous prenez c'est un peu
la légère non je sais pas avec un peu
c'est simple tu fais pour m'amuser star
planétaire je veux qui fait au début
quand j'ai commencé je voulais être la
star du monde et ça me tellement rien
dire que voilà voilà je suis contente
j'ai écrit des chansons les gens les
achètent les écoutes dans dessus le
reste c'est magique bien habillé c'est
bien non c'est parfait ils n'extraient
plus des merveilles propos c'est comme
ça ça me donne trois fois où elle se
touche à peu la junte a vu qu'en même
temps bon gens vous l'avez vu comme nos
jambes mais ophélie peu tout fait vrai
on dirait du feydeau petit deux pièces
dites moi alors sérieusement maintenant
est ce que vous vous masturbez beaucoup
c'était sûr qu'il avait une balle en
main tant elle était menée de manière
raisonnable ça vous arrive quand même tu
gardes le ferez-vous comme mais oui on
se marie bien sûr laurent
libération bras je veux dire en ce
moment je me dégoûte 1
je ne touche même pas
et lorsque ce single est un titre inédit
qui s'appelle give me more donne moi
plus sauvage et là on n'en sort pas je
suis désolé jean de vous exposer à tout
ça mais c'est vrai que alors ophélie
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si vous
posiez 30 kg de plus j'en sais rien on
va le savoir
interview trente kilos de plus que j'ai
trente kilos de plus vous poseriez
combat des exposants des métiers les
auriez combien
70 70 ouais ouais c'est pas lourd
influent 40 kg suivant mais chez compter
ses formes c'est vrai est ce que vous
feriez un régime si vous posiez de 30 kg
de plus
non parce que si je peux être tranquille
puis je pense que j'aurai des raisons
mouais
donc j'en ai rien à je riais quel
métier si vous posiez 30 kg de plus
alexandre musique j'aurai un gros cigare
dans un fauteuil en cuir et j'enverrai
des gens de faire tapis najjar avaler à
votre place
est ce que vous seriez plus heureux si
vous posiez de 30 kg de plus le nom je
pense pas non non vous seriez plus
grosses bonnes questions comme la bonne
réponse est simple arrêtez ce truc là
c'est du monstre si vous posiez 30 qui
veulent plus est ce que vous pensez que
votre mec qui aurait vu votre beauté
intérieure derrière vos bourrelets
j'espère que oui sinon c'est grave mais
il vous aimerez pareil et je sais pas
j'espère ce genre est maintenant un
magnéto
[Musique]
si vous posiez 30 kg le plus c'est ce
que vous couriez le premier soir ah non
je serai super complexe et je ne couche
pas le premier sort quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive notre grosse voilà
d'accord si vous posiez de 30 kg de plus
vous feriez l'amour dans quelle position
dans le noir et sur le dos comme ça
c'est moi raison d'achats ophélie winter
si vous posiez 30 que plus est ce que
j'aurai une chance avec vous je pense
que j'aurai tellement désespérée que oui
c'est méchant
j'accueille ophélie winter
[Musique]
l'oeuvre au tour d'ophélie winter voilà
d'amincir il a très bien fait que c'est
moi qui les fais comment c'est ophélie
toute première émission de télé
premières couvertures de magazines voilà
alors le retour de fédérer hinter c'est
sur m6 music black reçoit toujours bien
toute la journée quand il est fâché
favorite avec une émission intitulée
mission mi6 mèche mais si ça passe le
mardi à 21h pendant dix semaines alors
au départ c'est une émission américaine
donc vous assurez ophélie les plateaux
français vous avez tournée des plateaux
à miami dans la maison de gianni versace
très sympa j'imagine très sympa mais il
manquait un petit peu mais c'était très
beau cette maison est hallucinante
sodome et gomorrhe il ya madonna qui est
venu pendant les tournages qui est venu
voir les contestant les commandes
annulées
les compétiteurs gfr le pitch de cette
émission donc le résumé c'est treize
jeunes rappeurs qui rivalisent pour
empocher 100 mille dollars enregistrés
et enregistrer un album avec missy
elliott voilà c'est une espèce de star
ac version rap us way sans micro ouais
y'a pas de cours ils sont ils sont bruts
de décoffrage et elle les met dans un
bus et vas-y en avant guingamp sur une
émission itinérante dans un autobus
laurent on va regarder avatar sens de
garder votre caméra faisait lire magnéto
serge
[Musique]
mission mission
mais sur aisne spisiak musique c'est le
retour de winter voilà je vais changer
de place pendant le magnéto et tu as
réussi malgré ton brad a hissé sur ce
tas pourrait faire quand même
ouais ophélie le retour sur m6 c'est un
petit peu le retour à la case départ
parce que vous avez commencé sur sur m6
avait commencé c'est un peu le retour
dans la famille quoi c'est ça sur son
nez là où je me sentais bien et vous en
fait je n'avais pas prévu ni de faire de
télé ou de 10 kw à rien je j'étais
complètement au repos et c'est nicolas
gicquel le directeur de l'ofas le pdg de
la chaîne qui m'a appelé qui m'a proposé
ce truc là je me suis dit comme miss et
là je la connais a cédé ça reste tout en
famille dont je les fais comme s'agit
même pas discuter l'argent et ça ne me
ressemble pas du tout j'ai dit oui tout
de suite
mais vous paye mais quand même mais oui
pareil de plus l'émission
il croit que les contrôles fiscaux j'ai
l'impression que vous avez changé au pdg
j'ai mûri à travers malheureusement la
maladie et la souffrance mais samassa va
bien ouais j'ai pas mal changé vous
dites c'est comme si j'avais 50 ans j'ai
pas eu le temps de savourer mon succès
si elle seulement maintenant que je me
rends compte de la chance que j'ai eu un
peu comme si vous avez vécu toutes ces
années trop vite quoi
oui c'est ça tout c'est trop enchaîné
sont mes rêves se sont réalisés comme ça
vous vous mais j'ai pas agi pas pu
savourer quand j'ai pas eu le temps
c'était normal j'en ai un disque j'étais
numéro un c'était normal je faisais un
film je voulais faire un film avec
d'autres personnes je le faisais alors
qu'aujourd'hui je me rends compte que
même le fait d'être parti ne serait ce
qu'un an pendant ma maladie et puis un
en avant parce que je l'avais choisi
c'est vachement plus dur quand on
revient pas comme ça on n'a pas un
indice numéro un comme ça et donc je
suis je savoure en fait j'ai mangé mon
pain blanc c'est ce que je me dis
qu'est-ce que je fais là bas vmr d'antan
quand même
ou bien encore les créatures bon c'est
pas vieux 50 ans vous avez du succès à
20 ans c'est vrai et très vite un peu la
grosse tête faut bien le dire merci en
tant qu'outil puis suis en même temps
françois n'oublie pas que tu as mal au
bras va pas te faire rigoler sur les
canaris nantais d'un mois ça s'est passé
pendant avec le recul c'est c'est
complètement légitime logique que ça me
soit arrivée parce qu'avec tout ce que
j'ai vécu
ne serait ce que la personne avec qui
j'étais à l'époque c'était une fois tout
était complètement démesuré par rapport
à mon âge et amour à la victime était
prédestinée à la base pas c'était pas
tout ça qui était prévu vous dites on me
contrôler on me manipuler leur dire ça
c'est comme ça c'est pas moi qui si vous
dites sont excusés vos conneries peut
manipuler quand même parce que j'étais
jeune et plein de gens non on m'a
propulsé là dedans je connaissais pas
les rouages croisant forcément un petit
peu manipulé un petit peu mais descend
en avance que maintenant aujourd'hui
c'est fermé serré voulez vous a plu
cocktail hier matin un nouvel ophélie
sont derrière par le tour pour les voir
vous dites au fait je ne dis plus oui à
tout maintenant merde on la réduit cela
non non parce que j'ai tendance comme je
suis quelqu'un d'assez gentil et
spontanée je dis oui à chaque fois qu'on
propose un truc bien sûr c'est pas un
film the end au recel ou comme un saint
mais j'ai dit oui et après je me suis
dit comme lui dit oui à minuit je
me dis merde pourquoi j'ai dit oui et
j'y vais la mort dans l'âme et je le
fais gentiment avec le sourire mais ça
me fait profondément chez donc je veux
arrêter de faire ça parce que je me fait
du mal à moi même et après je me
déclenché des maladies comme celle dont
j'ai été victime donc est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez le sentiment
ophélie de prendre un nouveau départ
ouais le bon en tout cas ouais mais bon
départ on ne sait jamais si jamais ces
choses près c'est toujours se dire que
c'est un premier départ non mais c'est
vrai ce que vous dites aujourd'hui c'est
que tout ça c'était un tour de chauffe
et qu'aujourd'hui vous y allez vraiment
vous avez le sentiment de commencer
votre carrière aujourd'hui j'ai un jour
je commence aujourd'hui avec
l'expérience en biens et en
il passait et je pense que si je si je
garde ça en tête
y'a pas de raison que ça ne fonctionne
pas bien proprement coule toujours très
jolie forme à 100 mais ça va on est
désolé il va falloir attend alors il
faut attendre un peu
pas vrai que je me détende faveur alors
on a appris effectivement que sa vie
était gravement malade moi je ne savais
pas paralysie faciale
c'était double parade d'ailleurs j'ai
encore des séquelles quand je parle je
n'articule n'est pas déjà beaucoup mais
là c'est un peu un peu dur c'est un réel
effort pour moi de parler j'ai une
névralgie d'ernen donc sa part du coup
ça pousse ça bloque tout ça est double
névralgies denner trijumeau donc c'est
les nerfs tu gères la face avec des
crises de céphalées c'est des migraines
gîte à lariboisière de constater que tu
étais lariboisière moi j'avais tous les
deux jours faire d un filtre a sûrement
là mais c'est quoi je sais c'est quoi un
bug du sort si c'est une maladie qui
normalement attend les femmes
ménopausées qu'on était agent secret
qu'on a eu des vies overstreet sa force
de vie avait eu l'impression d'avoir 50
ans vous des femmes ménopausées
non mais c'est aussi c'est un truc de
fou quand même ils ne savent pas le
traité sur quelqu'un de jeune comme moi
donc j'ai fait pas mal de pitau j'étais
vraiment j'étais à 40 mg de morphine par
jour pendant très longtemps
ben donc je suis parti dans un autre
hôpital pour vous faire retirer toutes
ses aises tous ces médicaments et à la
faim en sortant le bien le docteur
général m'a dit bon vous avez ça soit
les patients atteints de cette maladie
en général il y en a un sur deux un
suicide parce qu'ils supportent plus la
douleur ce qui est à moi j'ai vraiment
des crises a tapé contre le mur je me
suis pété de neige les anglais en plasma
ça a été vraiment goldorak et l'autre ou
meurent de la maladie donc je suis parti
de l'epita dans le jeu vous allait
décéder très sympa et je rencontre un
maître zen qui lui m'a sauvé que la
médecine asiatique et donc j'avais en
médecine asiatique une frigories au
plexus
il renforce les trucs comme ça dans les
yeux le peintre horrible et jeu pendant
deux heures j'étais sous des couvertures
atteint comme ça et tout est sorti chez
les devants demain tout allait bien que
non mais c'est pas des conneries genre
on ne sait pas trop si c'est vrai on
frigories c'est quoi une frigo résea ans
c'est un commun il m'a expliqué en fait
chez les chinois il ya le yin et le yang
il ya le bien le mal il n'ya pas de ya
pas de tièdes et pas de front il ya le
froid le chaud mais ya pas de syed est
en fait c'est une énergie tiède qui
finit par se refroidir et qu'ils voient
c'est un peu quand on exclut je passe
pour une folle et donc il m'a fait
sortir toute l'énergie froide que je que
j'avais gardé deux en fait c'était dû à
des problèmes personnels que je me suis
complètement contracter quand on est un
peu nerveux on allait en général les
trappe à skis ce blog et toi moi j'étais
un bloc de pierre comme ça donc congelés
crispation congelés et donc sit-in
frigories l'effroi est parti j'ai su
bouillante épaule cassée
françois mais dont les névralgies
d'armelle ça vient d'où c'est dû à quoi
mais on sait pas c'est ça le truc c'est
qu'en plus on passe on des irm scanner
tout ça ça ne se voit pas on ne sait pas
ce que c'est donc les docteurs vous
prenez pour une table au début c'était
jeu j'avais décrit l'arrivée comme ça je
m'enfonçais les doigts dans l'eau pour
arrêter le flux sanguin je l'appuie et
très fort pour pas que la douleur parce
que ça vient que les battements du coeur
ça fait comme des coûts c'est là j'en
rigole mais c'est ça j'ai passé un an
monstre vraiment avec une douleur à
vouloir a souhaité la voir réellement
donc aujourd'hui je me réveille tous les
matins je suis en pleine forme c'est le
bonheur total
je l'avais la psychanalyse aussi ouais
ouais ok au départ pour pour savoir ce
que d'où ça venait je me suis dit j'ai
peut-être faire un bain bugs qui pas
passé qui bloque et inconsciemment
j'occupe complètement parce que je
travaille que voilà donc au départ j'ai
pris un an sabbatique à deux ans en me
disant justement je travaille là dessus
parce que j'ai pas de traîner ce fardeau
toute ma vie et j'ai cauchemar est en
fête avec presque les clés du du truc
elle m'a dit vous avez bien travaillé
jusqu'à ce que votre intelligence qu
elle est maintenant je vais vous donner
les autres clés quoi donc ça a été assez
rapide et sûr partie très vite et
avec les clés dont j'avais un trousseau
et ça va aider à vaincre ma maladie
qu'est ce que vous avez découvert sur
votre enfance c'est sur votre famille
quand vous avez fait ses gammes avait
des choses qui en fait des espèces de 2
comme on appelle ça de psychanalyse de
comptoir que je m'étais auto procurer à
savoir je suis malheureuse en amour
parce que mon père est parti quand
j'étais jeune et pourquoi il est parti
et je comprends pas maintenant il a une
famille d'être des enfants il est super
bon père et les emmène en vacances avec
toute la classe comprend rien du tout
donc j'ai pas l'excusé de me dire que
mon père n'a pas la fibre paternelle et
est en fait j'ai compris que la
psychanalyse donc comme comme ça me
juifs que mon père avait été placé
pendant la guerre dans une famille
catholique et et plus les nazis avant
c'est donc ma grand mère est partie dans
les corps également été que plus les
nazis avançait plus à chaque fois les
familles catholiques passé mon père est
comme ça tu as fait cette famille
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre et quand
avec l'abc et machin j'ai compris tout
ça j'ai regardé mon père a fait cette
famille avant de faire la huitième dans
laquelle il est vraiment papa poule
nickel et tout donc je l'excusent bien
compris ça je me dis comment faire le
jeu des prix l'attitude de veut faire
suite à ce qu'il a vécu pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale en fait voilà
parce que la psy m'a expliqué que tout
ce qui se passait quand on était très
jeune été répercutée toute la vie donc
maintenant j'essaie de postes est aussi
complice âgé célébrité fait une tire
fort bien perso ça va là nous traitent
maintenant vous êtes bien méchante trop
pleine forme
trop pleine forme maintenant c'est moi
qui vais soutenir mes copains qui vont
pas bien et c'est vrai que vous avez
revu prise bah je peux pas le cacher
puisqu'on a été papa radier
malheureusement sortant de boîte donc
oui alors que à prêter dans ma vie en ce
moment il se passe un truc marrant c'est
ainsi que je vois vraiment un cycle
passé quand je retrouve exactement les
mêmes personnes avec qui j'étais à 10
ans quand on s'est fait avec prins on
était comme des fous on a passé la nuit
à parler on est est comme si on s'était
quitté l'assemblée de quoi il en est
reparti comme en 40 ans fait de la
musique on est on est un peu rebelle
machin depuis on skie de plus on
n'arrête pas de s'appeler et plein de
gens comme ça la personne avec qui je
suis en studio c'était un flirt de 91
que j'ai embrassé dans une boue mais un
soir et qui est parti vivre à los
angeles et maintenant il se trouve que
j'enregistre dans son studio mon album
c'est que des trucs comme ça des gens
reviennent et c
j'ai l'impression que ça avec mon frère
mes sens inverse au départ c'était
c'était une bon train pour moi il
fallait que je me réveille maintenant
voilà bah voilà même si cela vous l'avez
revue je ne croise de temps en temps
c'est votre vrai amour lui mais tous les
amours sont des vrais hameau assez bien
alors que lyon va bien vénère divion
vous pensez à quoi en ce moment là
précisément à votre bouquin à ce jour
elle pu tester et non sans déconner
parce que je les lui je le lis comme sex
and the city comme je regarde les dvd de
saxon et j'en ai un petit peu puis je le
garde pour après parce que je veux pas
tout bousiller tout de suite et vous je
m'éclate voilà et je le lis en même
temps je fais ça tu à colorier un peu
mais c'est à françois françois k mais
pour
voir si la f1 et alors
on sent que ces mecs est très très
entraînés way de simuler oui c'est oui
mais c'est nul
ah non c'est pas nous c'est notre ancien
assureur sa pièce et ophélie oui quand
vous regarder dans la glace le matin
vous vous dites quoi
je me dis 95 2005
voilà ça veut dire 95 était comme ça en
2005 et sont comme ça je vous vois pas
mal la maturité et un bref instant j'ai
pas le choix c'est gentil mais c'est
joli aussi dessein d'en haut
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit à marilyn monroe quand
j'étais petit au plus belle histoire
d'amour c'est là qu'elle chiffré en bleu
y en a pas une bobo non sincèrement
c'est vrai frings était vraiment whaou
parce que j'ai déjà mes 17 ans je le
savais dès le début le déput c'est vrai
et il raconte le pompiste à monter des
marches la fout mal d'histoires très
belle histoire s'arrête pas là ouais ça
à l'époque j'étais gamin j'allais encore
à l'école j'allais appeler ce n'est pas
bon c'est un truc de fou
est ce que vous seriez prêt à tout
quitter pour le grand amour bien sûr non
non et non ces renvois 6
c'est pas vrai ce que d'envoi jamais
passer chaque jour à l'augmentation
offert de magnifiques trophées les
attend laisse les deux
c'est un truc là on appelle ses
camarades place
excuse moi mais sur touche par en
dessous ça suffit maintenant blague on
fait du non au oui quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois quand
j'étais malade j'ai plus de l'arbre je
fais que rire j'ai mal aux zygomatiques
être la journée jari vous changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique nom change rien je sais ça fait
vraiment prétentieux mais j'ai jamais pu
dire de ma vie mais jamais maintenant
c'est nouveau ça ouais c'est super mais
parce que vous n'aimez pas du tout moi
je me souviens je pouvais pas me
supporter je ne m'aime pas physiquement
parce que c'est de pire en pire plutôt
ménard matin
mais à l'intérieur c'est j'échoue
milliardaire voilà un chiffre en
milliards des jeux blizzard
qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire de plus
négatif sur vous au fait rien qui n'ait
jamais déjà été dit cent fois
ouais si votre vie était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez dans votre
vie ouf
tellement de choses tellement de choses
mais en même temps si pour en arriver là
oui ça va changerait pas
oui faut bien qu on en chie un petit peu
pour avoir envie de crier notre notre
truc quoi qu'y avez-vous le plus envie
d'épater aujourd'hui mois que
feriez-vous ophélie s'il ne vous restait
que 24 heures à vivre un truc il essaye
de placer son camion les garder
est ce qu'elle a dit
est ce qu'elle a dit l'amour etc
d'orléans non qu'est ce que vous avez
dans vos poches
au fait d alors au nom du garde irakien
tu te fous non troppo m je te promets
que je n'ai rien et vous ai déjà pensé
au suicide
quand j'étais s'est pas réellement un
suicide puisque j'étais pas qu'on sorte
à cause des médicaments mais j'avais
vraiment envie d'en finir
ouais bon allez de l'homme s'arrête
pendant que j'étais malade c'était
légitime c'est juste un petit peu shooté
aux médocs faut pas que yoshi
non non non j'ai pas tellement
d'histoires bonon encore françois il
prend un catcheur et enfin top five
c'est parce que j'ai écouté j'ai gagné
au fait qu'est ce que la vie vous a
appris et finalement la vie m'a appris
la vie c'est une phrase qui peuvent rien
dire mais pour moi ça veut dire bon
alors ça c'est pas mal hein ouais la vie
m'a appris la vie excusez menti durant
cette interview bien sûr le mardi soir
la scène
michel mais si c'est sûr
aïe aïe aïe j'aime pas ces trucs-là
yahia vous devez finir démission avec
une grosse moustache on parle de la
moustache
[Musique]
matière à bien
m
[Musique]
lee
bien qu elle est brune domaine c'est pas
très gentil
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
dinar du tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu